but that announces two major game delays
dead space gets an official release date
and more
we're exactly one month away from xbox
and bethesda's big summer game showcase
and bethesda is already breaking hearts
two of the studio's major games
starfield and redfall have been delayed
to 2023. starfield originally had a
release date of november 11th for pc and
xbox series x and s while red falls
launch date had yet to be announced but
was slated for this summer the new
release window for both games is
currently set for the first half of 2023
aka by the end of next june starfield
slip to 2023 is the more surprising
development of the two as back in june
bethesda's todd howard said that he was
positive that the game would avoid being
delayed but head of xbox phil spencer
also recently tweeted that he'd met with
bethesda so it's possible that the
decision to delay the game was discussed
at the company this week not too much is
known about arcane's red fall at this
point in time although leaked images did
suggest that the game will resemble a
fusion between borderlands style looter
shooter action and vampire hunting
starfield meanwhile is the next open
world rpg from the team behind elder
scrolls and fallout 3 and 4. the two
games being pushed out of 2022 suddenly
leaves a gap in xbox's first party
lineup though it remains to be seen how
or if that will be filled according to
bethesda gameplay deep dives for both
games are expected soon but on the
bright side at least there's another
space game coming out sooner that can
hold you over until starfield drops the
dead space remake from ea motive now has
an official release date as announced in
the latest dead space stream the game
will release on january 27 2023 for pc
playstation 5 and xbox series x and s
the publisher had previously announced
that dead space would be targeting an
early 2023 release date and this
announcement puts it as early into the
year as games tend to get before that it
was expected to release in 2022 and
reports circulated just ahead of the
release window announcement that ea
wanted to give it more time but in other
delay news teclan announced it's pushing
dying light 2's first major story dlc
from sometime this summer to sometime in
september called chapter 1 in the
footsteps of a night runner this update
is a new gameplay chapter that
introduces a new progression system new
enemies and rewards and several missions
and bounties as well as a highly
requested photo mode and speaking of
photo mode death loop now has one the
game's third major free update is out
now on playstation 5 and includes photo
mode additional accessibility options
and more so now it'll be even easier to
snap pictures of cult snapping visionary
necks to text to juliana wait you
couldn't send pictures on phones in the
60s but speaking of cell phones
activision has revealed a new call of
duty game is coming to mobile devices
and if you like that segway even two
percent click the like on this video
right now nickname project aurora the
upcoming title is a battle royale that
aims to deliver quote a fresh and new
way to play according to a post on call
of duty's website the project aurora
team has already begun playtesting the
game however don't expect to see or hear
anything about it anytime soon the
closed alpha is reportedly limited in
size and the select few who are playing
are prohibited from sharing any details
about the game publicly right now
however the content within the alpha is
still heavily subject to change and
speaking of changes can you tell
speaking of is like my favorite term
sony appears to have registered a new
playstation 5 model in japan as the
company received construction design
certification in april for a cfi 12000
device that uses updated radio equipment
this approval is likely for the
playstation 5 as it uses a
cfi1xx model numbering scheme so nothing
too crazy no slim ps5 to report on just
yet but hit the comment section and let
me know what you would want from a new
model of a playstation 5 and also react
a little bit to the delays this morning
because
what are we what are we playing this
fall god of war
i'll see you tomorrow
you